china is dealing with multiple coveted
outbreaks despite some of the toughest
pandemic measures in the world in some
areas there are actually welding shut
doors of people suspected of having
covet this all comes less than a month
before the opening of the beijing winter
olympics elizabeth palmer has more
with a budget of nearly four billion
dollars chinese winter olympic venues
are show stoppers
president xi got to watch the athletes
practicing last week and toured the
facilities but behind the upbeat photo
op is a vast invasive effort to stop
kovid spoiling the games
public health swat teams are testing 14
million people for the second time in
three days after an omicron outbreak in
tianjin which is commuting distance from
beijing
one citizen posted a video showing
panicked people at a market trying to
stockpile food they'd heard stories from
the city of jian where officials had to
step in and deliver meals to some
residents in their second week of
complete lockdown who said they'd run
out of things to eat
also in jian local officials welded shop
the door of a man suspected of having
being exposed to the virus massive
testing is going on in other cities too
with home visits to make sure no one
slips through the cracks and china has
launched a huge booster program offering
shots to anyone over three years old
authoritarian china wants a coveted free
olympics to impress the world
even though there won't be any foreign
spectators and all athletes will be
sealed in what's meant to be a virus
free bubble
for cbs mornings elizabeth palmer
bangkok